what's going
on I don't know what's go why are we out
here we're trying
to your what try to get
your okay open where she's up and
talking all right why don't you get out
of the car all right what' you You' been
drinking tonight no no no did you use
anything tonight no
no all right shut your car off she's up
now she's
up what what's going
on
no all right we got a call that you're
playing real loud music and I come up to
the car and you're pass out so what's
wrong with that well that that's an
issue no it's not okay well you're
clearly Under the Influence you're
clearly under the influence of something
I I had a what's up how how cuz I can
smell
alcohol okay is it I don't know right so
okay so stay right there stay right
there nothing okay do you have ID on you
yes I do okay let me say
it I'm ready no give me your
ID hey shut the car up for now okay grab
this you shut the car
off that was a bad move no it wasn't let
me see your ID than you did what's that
I thought smarter than you
did you want my ID yeah you have your ID
on you yeah come get
it let me
see what's up okay
perfect
all right why don't you step out of the
car
no what's up oh yeah okay
perfect what are you reaching
for chips okay yeah you have your ID
yeah okay that's what you want right yep
oh your ID is underneath you here yeah
you're sitting on it no you're know
where I'm at I'm sitting where I'm
sitting and you're waking me up and
you're disturbing my peace so please
take your light listen the reason
thank you thank thank you so much thank
you so much please turn that light off
listen the reason we're here is cuz you
were sitting here playing real loud
music okay I'm allowed to do what I want
to do well no cuz you were disturbing
the pce so how
not why don't you put that
down thank
you all right let's show you my body
cameras on okay just have to let you
know that
okay I just have to tell you that's
all so how much do you have to drink
tonight how much alcohol have you
had other than these uh two little
airplane bottles cuz that just fell out
of your car when you open the door
so didn't fall out it did when you just
opened the door it just fell out cuz it
wasn't there when I walked
up it was
no why don't you give me your
IDE
give me your ID please you're sitting on
it I know what I'm doing okay you're
just putting your jacket on yeah okay
cold okay that's fine I need your ID
you're demanding too many things no
you're you're not listening to anything
so no I don't want to listen to anything
you're right there you
go put your wallet back
on and I'll put mine back
on let me see your
ID highspeed chases we got up unruly
suspects I will kill that mother CH me
no do it stay in the bo I like it K
dramatic DUI I'm a pass kinding of do
and shocking body cam footage hey kill
the girl kill the gr law and crime
presents body cam the place for real raw
and wild police videos you should have
seen it it was good it's on body camera
I'll show it to you catch the action and
subscribe to our new YouTube channel
[Music]
now you just
wasted both of me and your time you just
did what I wanted you to do listen
either give me your ID or I'm just going
to take you out of the car and place you
under arrest for driving while
intoxicated okay so you can pick
one we'll start with that thank you
where do you live
at where do
you no okay what what brought you up
here okay why don't you uh step out of
the car and we'll do some uh FY tests
come on out of the
car I'm not asking you anymore just get
out of the
car no thank
you can I have my key
no
yes goodbye you're wrong oh yeah now
step out of my way please get out of
your car
no get no this why the LA wants me so
bad we got some yeah I'm I'm testing you
and test me get out of the car testing
you so let's I there get out yes yes by
sitting here that's right thank you he's
ordering you out of the either either
get out of the either get out of the car
I'm going to drag you out of the car and
you're going to go on handcuffs so you
can either come out and cooperate or I'm
just going to pull you out of the car
trying to work with
you work with me just get out of the car
NOAB you have no you have no other
option here either either get out of the
car willfully or I'm just going to pull
you out of the car and then you're going
to be under arrest so those are your
options for what obstruction under
arrest obstruction of justice for
ordering your we're giving you a lawful
order to step out of where is the
obstruction of justice you're not you're
not listening to us I'm telling you to
get out of the car right okay so either
get out now or I'm just going to pull
you out of the car and then you and
you're you're moving the wrong way and
but we're asking you we're asking you
and you're going to put the light on the
wrong way listen we're asking you you
get out okay so so what you want me to
start the car like adult no just get out
of the car just get out of the car so we
can do some so we can do some tests or
if you're not going to listen I'm just
going to put you under
arrest who's doing
test all right stop stop stop
stop put your hand behind your
back
okay
to my right now set up moving stay right
there don't
move we gave you ample
opportunity stand
up course
je
no were you wearing boots no I was
chilling I wasn't wearing anything you
you you minded your own business I
minded my own business I didn't allow
you to get in my car and move youring
flashlight so don't move your flashlight
you're moving your flashlight yo you're
moving your flashlight don't too fast
don't move too fast I'm relaxed I'm
relaxed no no you aren't stand right
here you aren't stand up against give me
a cigarette I will I will with my back
turn I will stand against my car with my
back
turn I will stoping go ahead officer try
me test me play me it's too late for now
yeah yeah it's too late you're right
you're right so call who you got to call
you're going to jail now so let's go
what did I do officer officer officer
officer ow officer you're pinching too
hard I'm just holding walk that way what
did I do walk no you're under arrest
thank you no thank you there's no there
is no no thank you no it is it is a yes
thank you and you're about to learn a
lesson you're not learning get in the
car
get in the car fucking thing
no get in the car not until I have my
own ke I drive for car right much could
[Applause]
y it was just one k i put it on top next
to my glasses yeah on top
somewhere where
I please you no too
late you're under
rust let me get a cigarette get in the
car get in the car thank you hey ow ow
ow ow no thank you get in the car no
thank you you know when I do this
podcast I'm conscious about what I wear
this is not by accident I want to be
presentable to all of you and there is a
place that I want to tell you about
where you can find clothing to buy and a
whole host of other things to buy it's
called deal dash what is that glad you
asked deal dash is an auction website
it's been around for 14 years and they
are now a proud sponsor of sidebar they
have awesome deals super exciting
auctions the way it works is you buy
bids and then you bid on things that
start zero dollar everything on the site
starts at zero doar and they gave me
Jesse Weber from long crime sidebar $100
which came out to $770 and let me tell
you when I say I'm bidding hard right
now on these psycho tuna bathing suits I
mean Summer's right around the corner I
want them no I need them okay so what's
the catch well you got to pay up front
to bid so for instance here after you
sign up they ask you to buy 400 bids for
30 bucks which means you can bid 400
times in any of their auctions by the
way they have some seriously quality
items like this brand new jeep that
someone won for
$1,875 a Nintendo switch for
$22 does deal dash for everyone no some
of the auctions can take hours or even
days on end so you need to invest time
for bidding but if you like bidding on
auctions and you've got the time on your
hands to figure out how it works you can
get some pretty sweet deals so check out
dealdash.com when you sign up use my
promo code law crime 100 and you get 100
extra free bids on your first bid pack
purchase and if you don't win an auction
using these bids or you don't like it
for any reason contact deal dash you get
your money back no questions asked on
your first bid pack purchase so the
downside is really limited it's worth a
try now once you're done finishing this
episode of sidebar of course you can
check out dealdash.com law crime1 100
well thank
you no thank you will you stop no I
won't I won't I won't until you fucking
to CH me prop you're under arrest just
get in the car yeah why go
watch oh you fed up youed up youed up go
ahead Speak Your Truth go ahead Speak
Your Truth stay in the car speak to
God sit back I'm going when I'm ready
give me a
cigarette yo cuz mying hands are right
here feel them they're fing
warm
right thank
you you good yeah yeah yeah stupid what
stupid what I know what I'm doing fck
you follow me keep doing it all right
all right yeah NOP thank
you no can you let me out here please
will you guys agreed
on one word let me out here cuz you
agreed that you were going to let me go
I didn't agree right
here so let me go
[Music]
officer no no you're not transporting
any my wings are shaking I'm not going
to no allow that please officer please
if you know it's good for the goose it's
good for the gander so turn to right
turn to the right there you go stop
right here
stop all right you're not good for the
fucking
G yeah I got an
ID Papa 4 46 Papa 165 he's got all of it
666 come on
69 let's
go drop me
off why you want to stop me so bad cuz I
was not doing
anything was not even
driving and you got a license in your
pocket
that's mine right no you don't cuz I
wasn't
driving therefore stop stopping
me cuz you're not going to catch me my
God is only going to catch
me my Lord Jesus
Christ I found God did
you I don't think you did
so yeah I'mma keep my ass turned to
you cuz I'm a pig I don't fucking Look
Backwards and I do what I do cuz I
handle my
handle you don't handle
yours you don't trust
God you trust God then you w't allow a
lot of
things so why would you want to lock God
up you're trying to slow God
down you trying to got up cuz you don't
want to do either of those
things
right yeah we're here in our right
pocket when I say right you go
left
I'm not feeling too well and you just
fucking took me out of my own
destruction right my path not yours my
path I'm ready ready y we're ready let's
go back up all right
okay on now back up a little more all
right there you go ready now you got to
come out back up a little more come on
no not on your terms my terms actually
you're wrong no you're wrong okay get
out get out get out get
out I will sit where I want to sit I
will stand where I want to stand so what
my back is against the wall what do you
need what else to smack my head huh I
don't want to do
that but you don't want to do that
that's right you're right so let's
fucking think
clearly yeah
think sit
here I got time I got more time in the
world than you think okay me too right
cuz I'm an alcoholic right and all I do
is drink but I ain't going to fucking
butter my fucking wings for
you no right I don't and I won't okay
so very good now we got that under
control you
go you something that you call come pick
you
up yeah was it your phone phone
number what you have a phone number what
was the question you someone that can
come you up yes okay are they local or
they from they're from fucking they're
from a far distance okay they're coming
to pick me up okay all right good that's
what we want
okay why why do you want me to get
picked
up right right right and then you guys
stood in my way the first time so come
correctly it don't come at
all
all I got is time babe yeah listen you
got married not me so let's go try again
my feet fucking certainly not not
surprised about that right huh not
surprised about that right you guys
stopped me so let's go try one more time
what the fuck am I stopped
for
wings for
mine let me
go or I sit pretty right here my hands
hurting my body cuz I'm sitting pretty
the wrong way I'm sitting pretty like
this okay and you watching me you the
one in my custody H and you watching me
right yeah okay so therefore let's make
the Right
Moves
yeah okay yeah why are you doing this
right now I this is protocol this is
what we got to do can you please take
these handcuffs off you I can't do that
right now okay I'm going to help you if
you take these T cuts off of me I'm
going to see what I can do okay can't do
that right now that's fine all right I'm
going to pull this back up put your
sipper back
up thank you could be a human being
right I am a human being I'm human oh
you got a hole in this pocket yes I got
a few
[Applause]
holes you have nothing
on all right let me
see all right let me see your other
foot all right you want me to zip up
your jacket back up
yeah thank you
officer you warm in here okay yes Jay
what is your Jay I can't tell you it's a
secret okay okay so so I see the okay
okay she she has
nothing
you want your shoes on are you okay well
are you going to get me shoes to put on
yeah sure if you want no no okay and
then let's start okay do you want to
work on somebody to come pick you up
especially if they're coming far away
why so you could leave I have my key in
my car I know exactly where it is you
don't know where it is that's your issue
so let's start with my problem you're
going to let me go and we're going to
start with you giving the keys
to the back of my hands because you
don't need to arrest me I'm not an angry
person I don't move in
Anger no you don't see nothing all right
so my camera's on okay I'm sorry just so
you know my camera's on that's your
license um so you're picking up Devon
yes perfect just need you to sign give
me a
pen uh here you go so if you want to
read this you can she's saying she's
been arrested for DWI she can't operate
a vehicle for at least 12 hours okay if
you want to read that you certainly can
and then uh right there I believe my
brother went through all of this here
yes
please thank you all
right that I will bring her out in just
a moment
[Applause]
okay
you going to answer the question or not
no I'm fine you're fine okay very good
so you're not hurt you're fine um You
release your court dates on your tickets
and the complaint if you have any
questions just call the court on Monday
morning okay all right thank
you